[Sylvia Earle]
I see things that others do not,
a different world...
a world that's changed enormously
just in my lifetime.
My backyard was the Gulf of Mexico.
That's where I first fell in love
with the ocean.
I think if others had the opportunity to
witness what I have seen in my lifetime
from thousands of hours underwater...
I would not seem like a radical at all.
It's a pleasure to introduce a scientist,
an engineer, a teacher and an explorer.
[applause]
The ocean is dying.
All of us... we are the beneficiaries
of having burned through fossil fuels.
But at what cost?
Sixty years ago,
when I began exploring the ocean,
no one imagined
that we could do anything to harm it.
I saw the after influence of what
we can do to the natural world.
Think of the world without an ocean.
You've got a planet a lot like Mars.
No ocean, no life.
No ocean, no us.
[Hugh Downs]  In 1990, she became
the chief scientist for NOAA,
National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration.
[Earle]  I went to one meeting...
and I was never allowed to go again.
[laughs]
I feel that I must resign,
and as a private citizen,
do what I can do with more freedom.
She's not afraid to say, "You know what
you're doing, and it's wrong."
[Earle]  I really speak for the ocean.
If we continue business as usual,
we're in real trouble.
[James Cameron]
She's made it her life's purpose
to make sure everybody else
understands what's going on.
[Fisher Stevens]
Sylvia has a wish for the planet...
what she calls her Mission Blue.
Protect the ocean in the same way
we now protect the land.
[Earle]  I wish for a global network
of marine protected areas
to save and restore the ocean.